Alam awaikum awaikum assalam l baraka in
a muslim family if some members commit
shirk and they knowingly do it and they do not
abstain from it then how do you talk to them is a question that if there are certain
family members are doing shirk and they do not do
shirk so how can we do dawa how can we ask them to
inform you sister you have to do hima you have to do hima
and
what ever skill you have of conveying the
message and
convincing them Ahmadullah if they don't listen you have
to listen level base you cant force
so Allah told the messenger in chapter number 88 verse
number 21
2 your job was to convey the message so sister
you being a family member poets whether it be your
parents brothers and sisters and your
children and your relatives try your level
best with what ever proof you have of
Quran Sunnah try and  Poets tell them that shirk
is haram with whichever best ability you have got to succeed at the best
level only thing you can
convey the message if you continue you will not be
responsible for it